et avec nous pour ce club clos spécial
débat entre trois sénateurs sur cette
réforme des retraites et j'ai le plaisir
d'accueillir à l'injorion dire bonjour
Merci d'être la sénateur les
républicains de la Haute-Saône Pascal
savely bonjour merci d'être avec nous
c'est Nathan communiste tu Val-de-Marne
et Martin lévrier bonjour merci d'être
avec nous sénateur renaissance des
Yvelines et Alex évidemment bonjour on
va parler de la réforme des retraites on
va faire le bilan de l'examen de ce
texte au Sénat et on va se projeter sur
la suite mais d'abord ce qui s'est passé
au Sénat est-ce que le Sénat sort
gagnant de ces 10 jours de débat pour
voile
et il y a eu des débats qui ont été
chauds comme on dit chacun a utilisé
tous les articles du règlement ou de la
Constitution la gauche pour faire de
l'obstruction nous pour casser
l'obstruction au bout du compte il y a
quand même eu des débats de fonds on va
quand même pris un certain temps sur les
débats de fonds et le Sénat oui je crois
que le Sénat sort pas non pas gagnant
parce qu'il y a pas de gagnant ni de
perdant mais le Sénat a fait honneur à
sa réputation de sérieux de travail
l'intérêt c'est celui de la France et
des Français il fallait qu'il y ait un
vote vous savez la démocratie c'est
quand même débattre mais c'est aussi
voté que chacun puisse voter pour ou
voter contre c'est ce qui s'est passé au
Sénat je crois que c'est très bien comme
ça
vous faites de ces jours ce matin c'est
un deux contre un
non
d'abord premier renseignement ce qu'on
vient de vivre là c'est que s'il fallait
en avoir la preuve c'est que ce
gouvernement est droite
et d'ailleurs ce que dit notre collègue
hollandais est vrai il est content il
est satisfait ça c'est un homme heureux
du débat du débat au Sénat qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé on a 10 49-3 qui précèdent
notre débat on nous parle d'ailleurs
d'un futur 49-3 et puis nous on a eu
l'article 38 le loi dans le cas d'un 47
pour réduire le débat 5 procédures et
concertées là je vous avoue moi je viens
ce matin mes deux collègues ils savent
que je ne mets pas en cause leur
légitimité vous le savez c'était mais là
vous avez travaillé tous les deux mains
dans la main depuis déjà des semaines
sur ce projet de retraite et on en a
l'aboutissement voilà donc on a un
gouvernement de droite auquel la
majorité sanatoriale a servi de béquille
sur cette réforme des retraites donc on
a une responsabilité nouvelle à gauche
sauf que c'est qu'un seul objectif
c'était nous empêcher de voter le texte
ou la vieille dit d'ailleurs on a fait
ce qu'il fallait pour que ce texte soit
voté parce que c'est l'honneur du Sénat
la démocratie ça se remplace pas on a le
droit d'être opposé à cette réforme
il y a deux sortes d'oppositions de
regard sur votre question la première
sur les institutions qui ont fonctionné
c'était important au regard de ce qui
s'est passé à l'Assemblée nationale le
Sénat se devait d'être exemplaire il a
été à peu près malheureusement
effectivement nous avons dû utiliser des
des recours de procédure qui autant les
puces passer mais quand on passe de 4200
amendements de mémoire au début du texte
à plus de 9000 à la fin du texte on peut
se poser des questions sur le
fonctionnement de l'opposition sur la
façon de faire de l'opposition c'est le
premier point le deuxième point quand on
me dit c'est mesures de droite ou mesure
de gauche moi je suis désolé depuis 4
ans effectivement la droite à chaque
PLFSS essaye d'imposer un amendement qui
est le recul de l'âge de la retraite
dont acte nous avons repris à notre
compte une partie de cet amendement mais
nous avons rajouté énormément de choses
et ça c'est pas la droite et si je
reprends la réforme verte 2010 c'est un
milliard de mesures sociales à peu près
si je reprends la réforme Touraine c'est
à peu près 4 milliards de mesure sociale
et si je prends la réforme que nous
proposons aujourd'hui c'est 6 milliards
et demi voire un peu plus avec ce qui
s'est passé au Sénat donc on peut pas
dire que c'est une mesure de droite ou
une mesure de gauche c'est juste une
mesure pour les Français et surtout pour
préserver notre système de solidarité
internationale qui est ce système par
répartition et qui protège les jeunes
qui a dit que c'était une réforme de
gauche oui mais moi je dis que je dis
que c'est une réforme équilibrée on peut
mais moi je suis plus dans le débat vous
le savez si je suis si je suis à
Renaissance et je suis plus dans ce
débat droit de gauche je suis
pragmatique j'ai toujours été convaincu
depuis que je fais de la politique on
était capable entre gens de moins de
volonté sur des périodes de crise comme
celle-là de rompre les crises là les
clivages trop drôle droite gauche pardon
c'est le matin excusez-moi
clivage qui existe toujours malgré tout
il n'est pas question de remettre en
cause l'histoire de la France mais il y
a des moments où on doit se retrouver et
trouver les la démarche la plus
intelligente avant de passer au fond du
texte c'est vrai qu'on a ici à des
débats tendus comme on en voit rarement
au Sénat on a eu des accusations
d'obstruction silencieuses contre des
occultes des accusations d'obstruction
déjà est-ce qu'il y aura un avant et un
après au Sénat c'est débat sur la
réforme des retraites
moi je suis au Sénat depuis très
longtemps même si j'en suis parti pour
aller à l'Assemblée nationale et revenir
au Sénat ce qui m'a permis ce qui me
permet d'avoir une vision des deux
assemblées je pense que c'est comme un
moment qui marquera l'histoire du Sénat
par parce qu'il s'est passé pendant
pendant 10 jours je jour et nuit
j'allais dire et puis sur une réforme
essentielle comme celle-là on a retrouvé
un peu au Sénat un clivage gauche-droite
parce que même si Monsieur salvadéli dit
que on est deux contrats ce matin il y a
quand même un clivage qui est revenu un
clivage droit de gauche et si on a le
temps d'en parler un peu au-delà de la
réforme des retraites moi je pense qu'il
faut aussi tirer le bilan de l'action de
la droite et de l'action de la gauche
depuis des dizaines d'années sur ce sur
cette question des retraites sur ce qu'a
fait la gauche sur ce qu'a fait la
droite sur ce que la gauche a coûté au
pays et 981 c'est plus de 2500 milliards
cumulés et de la gauche qui ont mis le
pays dans l'état dans lequel il se
trouve aujourd'hui c'est pas quelque
chose sur cinq ans sur 10 ans c'est
quelque chose sur une période beaucoup
plus longue nous quand on revient au
pouvoir à chaque fois on essaie de
remettre les comptes d'aplomb et la
gauche a mis la France sur le plan
financier dans un état absolument
lamentable voire monsieur Moscou ici
président de la Cour des comptes qui dit
que la France vit au-dessus de ses
moyens et que la France d'urgence doit
redresser ses comptes publics je pense
que ça vaut le coup à ce moment
historique ça vaut quand même le coup à
ce moment historique de faire le bilan
de l'action publique des uns et des
autres et pourquoi la France est dans
cette situation alors qu'est-ce qu'on
fait ce qu'on continue on continue à
creuser les déficits ou est-ce qu'on a
un peu de courage et on essaie de
redresser notre pays qui en a absolument
besoin et ça c'est pas quelque chose du
2 contre un mon cher collègue c'est la
gauche contre la droite on n'a pas fait
la même chose
là je comprends pas bien
c'est pas c'est pas la gauche et
notamment les communistes qui croisent
le déficit ce déficit sur lequel
gouvernement 80 quand on a fait la
retraite à 60 ans
c'est à dire que quand l'opposition veut
parler vous faites obstruction vous
faites qu'on puisse parler donc moi je
vais moi je me réfère aussi à votre
histoire moi je pensais avoir aussi
l'ancien ministre de Sarkozy je peux je
peux penser que vous avez failli plus
appel à des références à Sarkozy plutôt
que kamoskovici mais les choses changent
mais ce que je veux dire c'est que là
vous nous dites les déficits mais nous
on n'est pas sur les déficits je regarde
on annulait seulement les exonérations
de cotisation sociale 85 milliards en
2023 ça c'est pas la gauche c'est pas
les élus communistes qui l'ont proposé
c'est ce gouvernement ça ferait 18,4
milliards pour la branche vieillesse
donc toute l'argumentation sur
l'Apocalypse la vision apocalyptique du
déficit sur la sécurité sociale tombe si
on décide ses choix politiques c'est ça
la gauche alors on peut être d'accord et
nous avons vous la maison nous sommes
dans un compte confrontation de projets
de société de la valeur du travail au
bon sens du terme voilà on est sur ces
sur ces sujets là donc après évidemment
vous avez des arbitrages à faire j'ai vu
sur index senior sur qui n'est pas
d'ailleurs qui va à mon avis être pris
en compte par le Conseil constitutionnel
pour hors sujet du du débat de la
réforme
vous relancez le débat sur l'exode sur
les exonérations excusez-moi mais
n'oublie pas quand même se poser
c'est encore autre chose les
exonérations et on les a connu depuis
longtemps on favorisé en particulier les
salariés à petit revenu sur leurs heures
supplémentaires vous ne pouvez pas le
nier et ça c'est très important aussi
souvenez-vous quand François Hollande
supprime les exonérations sur les heures
supplémentaires mais moi je l'assume moi
je l'assume parfaitement et je dis et je
dis bah c'est vous qui en parlez mais je
vous dis la réforme 24 ans je croyais
que vous n'aimez
qu'il fallait pas se couper la parole
parce que vous attendiez faire
d'ailleurs à l'hémicycle à l'inverse de
j'assume j'assume parfaitement qui mais
c'est extraordinaire j'assume
parfaitement cette réforme j'assume
parfaitement qu'il y avait un déficit de
13 milliards et demi potentiel cumulé à
150 milliards qu'on ne pouvait pas
laisser à nos jeunes et qu'il fallait
les trouver les solutions pour supprimer
ce déficit j'assume parfaitement que la
solution proposée de demander des
efforts aux Français qui le peuvent de
travailler un peu plus est-ce que vous
voulez avoir la gentillesse
j'ai retiré mon amendement sur les
carrés le même que si c'est faux je vais
m'expliquer c'est très bien j'ai retiré
mon amendement pourquoi c'est très bien
pourquoi vous alliez me coller vous
allez me coller 500 sous amendements sur
mon amendement il faut expliquer juste
un petit peu à nos auditeurs ce qui se
passe c'est quand on dépose un
amendement il faut passer en il faut
passer devant il faut passer devant les
finances il faut passer mais je croyais
qu'on interrompait pas le le collègue
mais chers collègues allez allez allez
c'est la façon la politique de Monsieur
hein donc 500 sous amendements sur mon
amendement ça voulait dire quoi ça veut
dire qu'il fallait examiner les 500 sous
amendements avant mon amendement on en
avait pour 2 jours bien sûr j'ai été
obligé de le retirer de votre faute mon
cher collègue et j'aurais bien aimé
qu'on en parle de mon amendement c'est
pourquoi parce qu'on aurait fait quelque
chose de beaucoup plus clair on avait
les 64 ans on avait aussi les 43 ans de
cotisation en plafond et personne et
personne ne cotisait plus de 43 ans à
cause de la gauche on n'a pas pu le
faire et la réforme aurait été beaucoup
plus équilibrée et bien mieux
présentable avant de vous laisser
répondre parce qu'elle savait un point
Alex sur ce qui a été évoqué au Sénat
sur cette question des carrières longues
qu'est-ce qu'on en parle alors sur les
carrières longues et bien Senna à
valider le dispositif carrière langue du
gouvernement dans cette réforme des
retraites et ils ont même voté une
modification et ceux qui ont commencé à
travailler entre 20 et 21 ans pour en
partir à 63 ans c'était une concession
qui avait été faite par Elisabeth borne
la première ministre lors du débat sur
le texte à l'Assemblée nationale
concession faite notamment au députés
les républicains emmenés Aurélien
Pradier et donc cette modification a été
votée par les sénateurs je vous laisse
répondre sur cette question sur laquelle
mais bon après j'aurais pu ne pas
accepter mais c'est pas grave parce que
c'est vrai que c'est pas grave non non
c'est pas grave il est tout c'est pas
grave voilà je ne dis pas ce que je veux
dire c'est que il faut peut-être qu'on
débat de la réforme
64 ans 43 à nuités voilà ça vous l'avez
vu on l'a eu à l'article 7 ou là on
dégaine l'article 38 et mes collègues
ils ont aussi dégainé l'article 38 quand
il fallait parler d'amendement qui
concernait la place des femmes dans
cette réforme de la retraite tous les
deux vous l'avez voté et quand je dis
c'était co-organisé et qu'on efface à un
nouveau gouvernement sur cette question
des retraites c'est que l'article 38 a
été dégainé par votre président de
groupe monsieur retaillau par Monsieur
Patriat et par Monsieur Malhuret donc
voyez bien on a là une organisation de
procédure pour arriver à ses fins après
il y a des choses sur lequel nous avons
eu des débats et ça monsieur levrier
devrait nous dire la vérité c'est son
par exemple la clause de revoyure la
clause de revenir parce que c'est pas
fini c'est pas fini l'objectif c'est
quoi qui vient d'être décidé avec le
vote de du Sénat c'est dans un temps
assez court peut-être un an ou deux
d'aller encore plus loin
sur l'âge de la retraite et sur l'entrée
de la capitalisation écoutez ils ont
voté tous les deux la capitalisation au
nom de défendre la retraite par
répartition
des accords
je suis très à l'aise je me bats depuis
le début pour le régime par répartition
je me suis battu depuis quatre ans ce
sujet là puisque
la capitale uniquement la capitalisation
c'est une demande de la droite qui
demande un rapport je ne sais pas ce
qu'il deviendra je ne sais pas ce qu'il
deviendra en CMP d'ailleurs ce rapport
voilà première chose moi à titre
personnel je je ne vois pas l'intérêt de
la capitalisation dans le système par
réparation ou alors
et après politiquement politiquement ce
qui s'est passé à l'hémicycle
excusez-moi j'ai très peu pris la parole
mais je l'ai pris au moins une fois je
crois que c'était le dimanche ça fait
déjà deux jours que nous débâtirons
parce qu'on reprocher de ne rien dire
j'ai attendu tout un débat sur un sur
trois amendements je crois qu'a duré
3h30 j'ai résumé en une minute ce qu'a
dit la gauche l'ensemble de la gauche la
nupes en trois en une minute j'ai dit ce
qu'ils ont dit en 3h30 voilà et ils ne
m'ont pas contre il avait même remercié
d'avoir résumé à cette vitesse-là voilà
comment était le débat donc il y a bien
un moment il faut que 38 parce que sinon
[Musique]
à peu près alors sur le fait à peu près
vous n'avez rien dit rien proposé un nom
sur un mot sur le fond de la réforme moi
j'ai voté cette réforme je vais faire
plaisir je vais faire plaisir à
salvadelli après beaucoup d'hésitations
comme je vous l'avais dit d'ailleurs sur
ce plateau parce que je je voulais
quelque chose de plus équilibré je
voulais les 64 ans mais je voulais aussi
que les 43 ans ne puissent pas être
dépassés plutôt que l'usine à gaz avec
les Quatre Bornes parce qu'on a quatre
bornes maintenant évidemment on en a
rajouté une à 21 ans j'aurais préféré
qu'on annule ces quatre bornes et qu'on
dise voilà vous allez jusqu'à 64 ans
donc 16 ans depuis 8 ans 20 ans 21 ans
et on disait personne ne va au-delà de
43 ans c'était clair c'était beaucoup
plus équilibré en termes de réforme
mon mon système ma proposition c'était
quand même que du coup je faisais
beaucoup moins financer la réforme des
retraites par les gens modestes mais
beaucoup plus par non par les CSP+ qui
c'est une expression qui plaît bien qui
plaît bien oui donc je pense qu'on
aurait pu faire quelque chose
d'équilibré mais moi j'ai voté j'ai voté
parce que je considère que notre pays
est dans un état absolument
catastrophique et que cette réforme des
retraites elle fait partie d'un ensemble
qui nous permet peut-être d'espérer
redresser la situation du pays pour les
pour les jeunes pour les jeunes
générations c'est quand même de notre
responsabilité et j'ajoute un mot je
pense qu'il faut pas se tromper les
Français c'est pas contre la réforme des
retraites exclusivement qu'ils en ont
quand on interroge les gens ils n'en
peuvent plus pourquoi parce que des
millions de gens qui travaillent les
gens des travailleurs des gens qui
bossent qui savent tôt le matin n'arrive
plus à faire les fins de moi c'est ça la
vraie question c'est l'inflation qui
n'est pas compensée c'est une situation
sociale qui est très tendue mon cher
collègue macroniste et moi j'ai rien
contre Monsieur Macron et c'est pas une
situation qui est né comme ça il y a
quelques années mais c'est ça le fond du
problème il y a aujourd'hui une
inquiétude sociale terrible non notre
pays alors la réforme des retraites
arrive au mauvais moment sa cristallise
un certain nombre de choses et quand on
a interroge les gens est-ce que vous
êtes pour ou contre la réforme des
retraites dans des conditions pareilles
ils vont pas dire on est pour mais moi
j'assume chers collègues j'assume les 64
ans je regrette qu'on n'ait pas les 43
ans mais la situation elle est en ce
moment la situation est très compliquée
nous sommes dans une situation
excessivement compliquée effectivement
puisqu'on sort de deux terribles enfin
on sort nous sortons d'une terrible
crise qui était la pandémie suivie d'une
crise qui est en cours liée en partie à
ce qui se passe en Ukraine cette
situation effectivement non seulement a
été difficile mais a été angoissante et
c'est vrai que nous sommes dans un pays
où
assez dépressif mais depuis toujours cet
aspect ce comportement français de de
toujours être plus un kick la plupart
des pays tous les sondages le montrent
et face à cet ensemble effectivement la
période n'est pas la meilleure pour
autant on peut aussi regarder un peu
autrement si on regarde le gouvernement
ce qu'il a fait pendant la pandémie
c'est le gouver à des gouvernements du
monde qui a le plus protégé les Français
et en particulier les plus faibles en
protégeant leur emploi en les salant en
gardant leur salaire etc et ça si on le
rappelait au français regardez ce qui a
été fait pendant deux ans pour vous
protéger pourquoi tout d'un coup
deviendrons-nous des épouvantables
capitalistes comme vous le dites qui ne
pense qu'à une chose à la finance
exactement le contraire nous voulons
continuer à la protéger mais dans une
logique effectivement de rétablissement
des comptes des comptes
incroyable c'est catastrophique qu'on
utilise le covid cette terrible guerre
de la Russie contre l'Ukraine etc je
pense il faut une honnêteté
intellectuelle notre collègue
joignantais il l'a dit ça fait des
années des années que la droite veut la
retraite à 65 ans le président de la
République l'a dit voilà faut mettre
carte sur ta faut pas faire covid la
guerre ceci cela voilà il y a un choix
non mais c'est un choix de société voilà
non c'est un choix d'accord faut faire
un peu de politique quand même c'est un
choix politique voilà c'est un choix
politique
je pense qu'on est dans une situation où
certes la question de l'inflation
préoccupait vraiment les Français mais
si j'écoute
alors faut changer l'opinion publique
faut changer les Français ça me rappelle
mon jeune engagement dans vos fins des
années 70-80
il y avait Giscard et on nous disait
Giscard disait faut changer les gens
faut changer l'opinion etc moi j'étais
jeune à l'époque et j'ai voté à gauche
et j'ai été très content que la gauche
se gagne et la gauche a été la retraite
à 60 ans est-ce que la France a connu un
cataclysme est-ce qu'on a vécu une
période apocalyptique ça a été pareil
avec les 35 heures quand on est passé au
35 heures on était là on est restés la
cinquième puissance de productivité
c'est à dire que le travail le travail
de ceux à qui on va donner deux années
de plus ont permis à la France d'être au
cinquième rang de la productivité
mondiale donc à chaque fois il y a ce
discours à apocalyptique après on est
dans une situation où quand même il y a
un gouvernement qu'utilise le 47,1 enfin
regardez le nombre de procédures qu'on
vient d'avoir sur une réforme qui serait
normale naturelle de bon sens d'esprit
de responsabilité
cinq procédures à s'exceptionnelles sur
ces dernières décennies d'ailleurs quand
vous étiez ministre sur joliandais je le
dis là il y a eu même dans la réforme de
2010 il y a une mise à contribution du
capital il vous rappelez bien vous avez
vous avez été un peu là-dessus là il y a
aucun effort demandé au capital c'est
une réforme ou les efforts sont demandés
au travailleur au travailleuses aux
jeunes aux femmes à tout le monde y
compris jusqu'au seniors rien n'est
demandé au capital les dividendes
qu'est-ce que vous voulez les Français
moi je veux bien les changer
et là on prend une cotisation sur les
dividendes on ramasse 14 milliards vous
croyez pas que les Français les
Françaises qui travaillent et ceux qui
voudraient travailler vous croyez pas
qu'il trouverait normal qu'on touche un
peu aux dividendes pour finisser pour
financer notre système de répartition il
y a un problème de répartition de la
valeur ajoutée franchement vous les
communistes vous changez pas les gens
vous les communistes vous êtes donc pour
la suppression du régime par répartition
c'est ça si vous touchez au bien vous
changer le système basta la mise a mis à
contribution du capital vous avez par
exemple vous exonération familiale les
employeurs est-ce que tous nos auditeurs
et nos auditrices le savent la politique
familiale exonération
ce sujet puisque j'ai dit ici au moment
où on discutait la retraite j'ai dit ici
je collègue collègue ça le venez j'ai
dit ici lorsqu'on discutait la retraite
oui c'est sûr qu'on a le droit mais j'ai
du mal parce que je ne connais que les
marques de pâtes
je prononcent bien en italien
ce que je voulais dire plus sérieusement
l'immigration qui a bien aidé quand même
je suis content parce que notre
discussion reflète aussi l'ambiance
qu'il y a au Sénat où on se respecte et
où on peut travailler sérieusement tout
en étant quand même dans la dans la
cordialité voilà et non ce que je veux
dire c'est très série usement c'est que
moi j'avais dit sur ce plateau que
j'étais pas du tout hostile à ce que
l'on est un complément de de recettes
qui viennent de la fiscalité donc on a
vous voyez qu'on a on peut aussi se
retrouver sur un certain nombre sur un
certain nombre de points et j'ai pas
déposé d'amendement
dans une réforme dans une réforme aussi
contrainte vous savez très bien qu'on
n'a pas pu déposer tous les amendements
qu'on voulait puisque celui sur les 43
ans vous m'avez obligé à le retirer avec
vos avec vos procédures d'obstruction
donc ce que je veux dire simplement plus
sérieusement c'est que si on avait dit
les 46 ans les 43 ans pas plus
effectivement ça coûtait un milliard et
demi c'est le ministre qui l'a dit en
séance et on aurait pu ajouter une
recette complémentaire pour le compenser
voilà ce qui aurait été pour moi la
réforme idéale
si vous faites ça vous changez le
système par répartir mais dans ce cas il
faut le dire moi je suis pas contre un
débat à ce sujet là mais il faut le dire
il faut dire aux Français on ne veut
plus répartition mais pourquoi je dis ça
aux Français c'est tout je dis ça
pourquoi pas on était intellectuel parce
que la réforme qu'on vient de faire elle
ne suffira pas la répartition si on veut
la sauver en tout cas partiellement on
sait très bien que dans 10 ans on aura
pu suffisamment d'actifs pour financer
les retraités donc là on fait une fois
de plus une réforme à court terme mais
il faut quand même avoir une réflexion à
long terme pour savoir si notre système
danse dans son organisation actuelle et
ce qui tient dans 10 ans on sait très
bien qui tient pas donc oui à la
répartition oui à la répartition très
attachée à la répartition je suis
gaulliste mais en même temps il faudra
bien mais en même temps il faudra bien
mais en même temps il faudra bien
envisager des recettes complémentaires
si on veut que ça tienne dans la durée
voilà c'est tout ce que j'ai dit on va
parler de la suite la suite c'est demain
la commission mix paritaire Alex député
sénateurs qui doivent se mettre d'accord
mais oui la fameuse CMP 7 députés et 7
sénateurs vont négocier pour trouver une
version commune de la réforme des
retraites alors un compromis sur ce
texte est probable puisque les
parlementaires les républicains et les
parlementaires Renaissance sont
majoritaires dans cette réunion mais les
sénateurs LR l'ont dit ils vont être
fermes dans la négociation car ils
veulent conserver les apports du Sénat
sur ce texte alors cette réunion
effectivement elle aura demain à 9h en
cas d'accord le lendemain jeudi chaque
chambre du Parlement votre assure
l'ensemble de cette réforme des
retraites et en cas de désaccord de la
CMP et bien la réforme des retraites
repartira pour une nouvelle lecture au
Parlement d'ici au 26 mars une question
annexe et une question Martin lévrier
puisque la gauche a demandé hier
justement à ce que cette réunion de la
commission mixte paritaire soit publique
ce qui n'est pas le cas normalement
est-ce que vous vous êtes pour la
publicité de cette commission ça n'est
pas prévu par la Constitution ça n'est
pas la Constitution et je crois que
c'est encore moins par définition
d'ailleurs ça n'est pas dans les
règlements de l'Assemblée nationale moi
c'est obsession de la transparence me
fait un peu sourire c'est à dire que
quand on est dans la minorité on veut
une transparence absolue comme si en CMP
nous trois nous en avons fait c'est
certain il y a pas de loup dans les CMP
il y a un travail un peu un peu comme à
l'hémicycle un véritable travail de
recherche de consensus quand on peut ou
de désaccord quand c'est un désaccord
mais il y a rien à cacher mais il y a
rien à montrer non plus on travaille de
façon cohérente concrète et c'est très
bien comme ça moi je branchement ça
n'est pas de la transparence donc je
trouve ça parfaitement inutile comme des
vins mais inintéressant au possible
totalement inintéressant comme comme
sujet pour moi
d'abord il faut me dire à nos auditeurs
et nos auditrices il y a cette
participant qui n'ont pas de mandat
les députés vont avec quel mandat à la
CMP l'assemblée n'a pas voté
je pense qu'il y a on est devant un
tennis démocratie y compris dans le
débat politique dans le débat politique
il faut être factuel chers collègues les
7 députés qui vont siéger au-delà de
leur étiquette politique n'ont pas un
mandat leur institution c'est quand même
un vrai problème quand même moi non mais
deuxième chose que je veux dire une
question
juste est-ce que c'est sur le sujet
qu'est-ce qui se serait passé puisque
les parlementaires qui viennent de
l'Assemblée nationale n'ont pas de
vraiment là puisqu'il y a pas eu de vote
on est d'accord on est d'accord qu'ils
ont pas de mandat que on est d'accord
sur certains il y a eu des articles qui
ont été votés quand même mais sur les
articles même j'ai une question une
question et si le Sénat à son tour grâce
à ce que vous avez essayer de faire à
cause et si ou ou
à cause allez trouver des éléments de
langage commun allez allez et si le
Sénat lui aussi n'avait pas voté dans
quelle situation
institutionnelle se trouverait-on
aujourd'hui et comment est-ce qu'on
pourrait regarder les Français par
rapport au Parlement et au mandat qui
est donné au parlementaire si c'est pas
voté est-ce qu'il y aura une commission
mix paritaire deux choses alors là j'ai
une autre question
c'est pas ça je vous le dis moi j'aurais
pu prendre plus de temps moi j'étais
pour qu'on aille au bout du débat non
vous ne voulez pas de jeunesse
parce que là franchement c'est pas très
sérieuse c'est pas vrai c'est pas ça on
aurait pu prendre plus de temps et aller
au bout de l'examen du Sénat sans la
batterie
celle du gouvernement conjointe à celle
du Sénat arctique 38 du Sénat 44 3 par
le gouvernement du soft qui choisit les
amendements du Sénat voilà vous avez
accepté l'agenda du gouvernement ça je
veux dire voilà c'est c'est je dis pas
que c'est illégal que voilà vous avez
ces politiques c'est politique vous avez
accepté l'agenda du Sénat je reviens sur
cette CMP moi je dis que c'est comme une
question le fait que 7 collègues député
que je respecte totalement mais qui
n'ont pas un mandat de leur institution
parce que la Constitution a prévu qu'il
faut dire à nos auditifs et nos
auditeurs et après il y a plus
d'amendements possibles après la CMP ça
on est bien d'accord on est d'accord
là-dessus il faut qu'un jour il faut
qu'à un moment donné
match de foot ou il est mené à zéro et
il dit à l'arbitre on arrêtera quand
j'aurai marqué mon but désolé miamment
les choses s'arrêtent sinon la France
n'avance pas et si on gouverne avec ça
on n'est pas sorti quand même bah la
profonde je veux dire moi qu'on fasse
des ponts on peut plaisanter un peu mais
il y a un moment faut aussi expliquer
les fait quand même il y aura plus
d'amendements ben c'est la loi c'est la
Constitution
il faut bien que ça avance il y a un
moment
je vais vous dire très sincèrement voilà
on peut trouver sortir
si on veut que on peut trouver toutes
les parades voilà là pour le moment on a
un problème l'opinion française reste
malgré tous les heures de débat et les
positions des uns et des autres
l'opinion publique française est contre
cette allongement de deux années voilà
des 43 à l'unités on a des décisions
politiques qui vont être prises qui sont
majoritairement rejetés par les Français
et les Françaises et y compris des gens
d'obédience de droite c'est rejeté par
l'Inter syndical donc voilà il s'agit
pas à faire seulement des questions de
procédure on a une question politique
qui nous est posée est-ce qu'on est-ce
qu'on la soit un projet une conception
du travail une conception de la sauce
société qui va à l'encontre de la
majorité des Français des Français c'est
une question sérieuse qui mérite autre
chose que des réponses une petite
réponse
si vous me permettez qu'on ne vote pas
qu'on ne travaille pas nous les
parlementaires en fonction sondage ça
n'est pas notre rôle et que c'est pas
les sondages qui font la loi et qui font
la France et qui font ce que sera la loi
en France donc notre rôle c'est d'avoir
c'est d'avoir parfois du courage et
d'annoncer des décisions qui sont pas
toujours simples à faire parce que si on
ne les fait pas moi je vous rappelle que
c'est passé depuis 40 ans et si on parle
de la santé l'absence de décision sur le
numerus clausus par exemple par
l'acheter par faiblesse a fait
qu'aujourd'hui on est en crise de la
santé et bien là aujourd'hui on dit
qu'il va y avoir une crise sur les
retraites et bien nous l'assumons et
nous faisons des réformes courageuses
qui ne sont pas de fait à plaire au
sondage les gens du gouvernent pas avec
les sondages de débat on va parler du 49
3 est-ce que le 49-3 est inéluctable ça
dépend beaucoup des républicains surtout
du président de la République parce que
c'est quand même lui qui a emmené cette
réforme autant je l'ai voté après
beaucoup de réflexion autant je pense
qu'elle arrive vraiment pas au bon
moment parce que dans une crise pareille
on aurait pu éventuellement choisir un
autre moment mais mais là on est on est
sur on est sur un texte qui nous est
proposé on vote ou votre pas c'est pas
nous qui sommes c'est pas nous qui
sommes responsable de l'agenda voilà
donc maintenant
dans la balle elle est dans le camp de
l'exécutif et d'être dans le camp du
président de la République
elle est pas dans le camp des élèves
voter l'amendement dans le PLFSS donc
des novembre vous vouliez ça en novembre
je vous ai dit tout à l'heure que on
avait voté le texte j'assume d'avoir
voté le texte moi j'assume j'ai pas de
problème avec ça je dis juste que ça
arrive dans un mauvais moment à un
moment où les Français les Français sont
excédés et que ça arrive pas au bon
moment donc le calendrier c'est pas nous
qui l'avons si vous me demandez un
pronostic si vous me demandez un
pronostic si le président de la
République veut aller jusqu'au bout sauf
à ce que je me trompe mais je reviendrai
pour vous dire que je me suis trompé je
pense ça va être compliqué de passer à
côté du 49-3 voilà ce que je pense parce
que pour être sûr d'avoir une majorité à
l'Assemblée nationale compte tenu des
questions que se pose un certain nombre
de parlementaires pas que chez les LR
partout ça va être compliqué quand on a
une majorité relative de la transformer
en majorité absolue sur un texte pareil
dans un moment pareil donc ça va être
compliqué de passer à côté du 4 9-3
réponse très simple un peu comme celle
que j'ai fait tout à l'heure il y a une
CMP
si elle est pas conclusive ça sera un
autre débat donc attends
je supporte pas donc marche par marche
il y a une CMP travaillant faisons
confiance à ceux qui travaillent la CMP
et aboutissant une CMP et le sujet du
potentiel du 49 3 viendra après s'il y a
une CMP conclusive donc le sujet c'est
la CMP aujourd'hui et demain
un mot les seuls qui vont être mis à
contribution sur cette réforme c'est les
collectivités territoriales et les
Hospitaliers donc quand on nous parle de
la santé parlons concrète ça sera pas
les dividendes ça sera pas les profits
qui vont être mis à contribution et ça
c'est dit et
49 3 y en a marre ça fait 10 49-3 donc
moi je dis il faut utiliser toutes les
procédures et c'est normal que les
députés se posent la question de la
motion de censure c'est normal qu'on
pose la question d'un référendum
d'initiative populaire il faut que les
Français qui apportent les Français les
Français se tranchent faisant un
référendum voilà vous et là ça sera pas
un sondage
de la vie des Français et des Françaises
voilà c'est ça voilà
allez
[Musique]